[Music]
we don't talk about bruno that's a shot
of colombia the song we don't talk about
bruno no no from the anime animated
movie no laughing lin in kanto sort to
the top of the billboard charts the film
introduces us to the colombian madrigal
family who live in a magic house
the emotional high point is the song
dos origitas
[Music]
that song is nominated for an oscar
thank you very much the songwriters
lin-manuel miranda and the singer
sebastian yatra they join us in the
studio welcome welcome gentlemen i have
no idea and what they're saying i had to
get the translation but the minute i
heard it the minute i heard it i felt it
so deeply touch your soul it really does
it goes right in there in the heart it's
very different from any other song in
the movie yeah
yeah i think that's what makes it
special is this is one of the only times
a character's not singing the song it i
really the goal was to write a folk song
that feels like it's always existed um i
wrote a nature metaphor about these two
caterpillars who are in love and
are scared to let each other go but you
have to you have to let each other go to
for the miracle to happen for you to
become the next version of yourself and
that felt like a metaphor not only for
what abuela and pedro are going through
but what this whole family is going yeah
yeah throughout the movie the movie
number one is beautiful it's so it's a
feast for the eyes too sebastian before
we talk to you i love when you found out
that it was nominated for an oscar thank
you for posting it on instagram here it
is
here are the
nominees for achievement in music
original song
be alive from king richard
[Music]
that's great i like that house
you're invited
it's in colombia in the mountains
but sebastian what was so interesting to
me about you started jumping before they
all they said was dawson you just jumped
out of your skin whatever spanish song
they were going to read yeah it was it
was the only those that they were going
to say
especially when they put the accent like
those
so what did you two know each other how
did this come about no we were just sort
of mutual fans actually tom mcdougall at
disney put us together and i was so i
was so intrigued by the idea of
sebastian singing his voice is so
angelic and so beautiful and uh so we
got on a skype and um i just you went in
with your musicians and i was like i'll
see you on the other side yeah so what
did it mean for you to be able to sing
this in colombia uh it means so much
just the movie in general
from the get-go was already like
something huge for for my country and
for latin america in general like
seeing that they're making movies based
on on our culture like it started with
coco and now with encanto as soon as
disney like posted like a year back like
a little clip i was like oh my god
they're making a movie about colombia i
want to be a part of it yeah but i
couldn't call them manuela or call
disney and be like hey put me in put me
in comfort zone but when my manager
called me and she's like hey so they
called from disney you know and i'm like
yes yes yes whatever it is say yes uh
they sent me the song it was so
beautiful and it it makes me so happy i
i feel
like this is a milagro for me you know
and kanto's giving me my own
gift yeah it's a gift uh it's a miracle
and uh thank you for this miracle my
friend it's beautiful and it's done in
spanish regardless that was also
something that's typical though usually
these movies go all around the world and
they find a local musician to sing it in
whatever the local language is but
you're keeping it in spanish how come
yeah and that was really exciting too
because i always love when disney
releases their super cuts where it's
like here's let it go in 21 languages
one of my favorite
languages but all over the world
was in spanish and that was important
one because we're representing colombia
i also think that because this is
abuela's song and she's the foundation
um of this family and this story is the
foundation of his family was very
important to keep it in spanish um all
over the world yeah now sebastian are
sebastian uh i know i noticed lynn said
it's the best you almost don't listen um
you're you're on tour and your album is
a hit um why do you believe your music
is resonating right now with english
audiences and all around the world i
think it it it has a little bit to do i
see you with it oh no i wore this on
purpose for you red heels
because he's got a hit song red heels i
wore this for you thank you for noticing
savannah
sebastian yes um you know it's i think
it has a lot to do with what happens in
in
and
and
lin's writing which is like just honest
from his heart and i've always tried to
do that with my music and now more than
ever with this album dharma and i'm so
inspired by songwriters like him and
other songwriters that i listen to their
music and it's like i know uh that
there's so much more behind it than
wanting to like
get something out of the song it's just
like you're focused on the emotions
there's real things happening there's a
first and last name on many of these
songs on the album you know like
when you write them about actual
situations and actual people and i i mo
a lot of the songs aren't like to be
sung on the radio taco rojos i wrote it
because i wanted to send it on whatsapp
to somebody and
let's go to here you know so it's like
there's a lot of truth in it i guess
lynn if you win an oscar you will be the
youngest person to have an egot i know
that's not something that consumes you
because you do what you do because you
love what you do but do you ever take
that in wrap your brain around what
you've accomplished at this stage in
your life no it's it's really you know
it's funny like it's really kind of an
interesting stat like i was i was
watching the australian open watching
rafa nadal break the record of most
opens but like he's not thinking about
that when the ball is coming at him at
140 miles an hour and i'm not thinking
about that at the piano i'm thinking you
know what does abuela want to say what
does luisa need to say to her sister and
then you look up and you know the the
stats are the stats and that's what's
cool about it is that's a cool club like
rita moreno is my hero john legend is my
hero bobby lopez is one of my closest
friends he's in that club so it's a cool
club but like that's not what you think
about you think about you know what's
the moment and telling the truth you've
got two kids of your own four and seven
one name sebastian yes
right right in the age group for encanto
so we were talking in the green room
it's like the new personality test which
character do you identify in the with in
the movie what about your kids yeah my
my oldest sebastian is definitely camilo
like he says daddy they sing it on the
bus and they sing all the parts we don't
talk about bruno he goes icing i am one
of several camilos
and then it's interesting my
four-year-old you know he like he likes
bruno too but he loves um waiting on a
miracle which is mirabelle's song yeah
you know he's little and he's all cheeks
and he just sits on the couch and goes i
can't move
the cutest thing i would break the
internet if i allowed my kids online but
i keep it for us
yeah you're busy what's next
me i got some dental work i got to get
done
no i'm really i'm i'm i was wondering
about your teeth i'm refilling my i'm
refilling my cup this year i'm just
really taking it easy because i had four
movies last year like
i need to you deserve a little break
you're a little busy and is it just or a
guitar or because
who's from her parents are from el
salvador and honduras said i was saying
it wrong
all right you got it gayle okay manuel
miranda and sebastian yatra thank you so
much for blessing us with your presence
thank you for coming thank you